culièrement vous suivre sur ce dossier
entend porter la balle est un monsieur
denis jacquat monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur le
ministre la commission des affaires
sociales a souhaité se pencher sur la
question de la prévention spécialisée en
créant une mission d'information dont je
suis président et ma collègue ra
bouziane laroussi la rapporteure
le moment était particulièrement bien
choisi et les nombreuses auditions que
nous avons déjà conduite témoigne que
nous sommes très attendus sur ce sujet
les éducateurs spécialisés bd réaliste
depuis très longtemps un travail aussi
difficile que dispensable pour aller à
la rencontre des jeunes en difficulté
créé un lien de confiance avec eux et
les aider à construire ou à reconstruire
leur parcours la nécessité de ce travail
sur le terrain réalisées par des
professionnels bien formés et renforcée
par les problèmes de radicalisation et
de montée de la violence que nous
connaissons nous demandons donc
davantage aux éducateurs et nous avons
raison car ils ont beaucoup à apporter
la prévention spécialisée traverse
cependant à un moment difficile
la contrainte financière qui pèse sur
les départements les oblige à faire des
choix qui préconise la prévention
spécialisée qui constitue en l'état du
droit une dépense non obligatoire pour
les conseils départementaux
monsieur le ministre il me semble que
nous devons profiter de cette crise
existe existentielle de la prévention
spécialisée pour rappeler l'importance
et l'utilité reconnaître qu'une telle
action nécessite des moyens qui doivent
être confortées et accompagner
l'évolution ce métier pour en faire un
précieux outil face aux nouvelles
menaces qui pèsent sur la jeunesse de
notre pays
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il s'agit d'un
sujet qui dépasse très largement les
clivages habituels
vous avez d'ailleurs indiqué vous même
monsieur ministres le 29 avril dernier
que la prévention spécialisée était trop
souvent le parent pauvre protection de
l'enfance monsieur le ministre est ce
que vous partagez ce constat quelles
actions votre gouvernement anti de
mettre en oeuvre pour donner à cette
action une base légale plus solide et
pourra sauver des associations inquiètes
sur l'évolution de leur financement
merci là par l'état monsieur patrick
kanner ministre de la ville doit gérer
ces des sports
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
député denis jacquat
donc je connais la sensibilité sur cette
question vous avez raison de poser la
problématique telle que vous l'avez fait
et j'aurai le plaisir de venir devant
votre commission que vous présidez et
que rapporte madame kerra bouziane vous
avez raison de cette préoccupation parce
que les missions de la prévention
spécialisée aujourd'hui dépasse
largement y compris le champ ministériel
qui est le mien au travers de la
politique de la ville nombre
d'associations de prévention connaissent
des baisses importantes et dans certains
départements elle est devenue
malheureusement une variable
d'ajustement
aussi le gouvernement agit tout d'abord
avec la loi sur la protection de
l'enfant largement soutenue par votre
assemblée est ici porté par madame le
ministre laurence rossignol
cette loi a conforté la prévention
spécialisée dans le champ de la
protection de l'enfance par ailleurs au
cours de ces dernières années le secteur
associatif a investi le champ de la
prévention de la délinquance mais aussi
vous l'avez rappelé le champ de la
prévention de la radicalisation
les grands réseaux ainsi accepté à notre
demande de participer pleinement à notre
stratégie nationale porté en juillet
parce qu'elle faisait précisément de
l'accompagnement des jeunes les plus
exposés les plus fragiles une priorité
plus récemment le 14 octobre dernier
avec mes collègues d'un à 15,9 laurence
rossignol hélène geoffroy nous avons
signé une convention de partenariat avec
notamment la df la rfa france urbaine et
le comité national de liaison des
acteurs de la prévention spécialisée
elle vise à renforcer les moyens de ce
secteur et surtout à émettre un état des
lieux exhaustif de la question des
financements qui vous préoccupe à juste
titre parmi les enjeux mis en lumière il
ya notamment le fait de mener des
actions
le soir le week-end pendant les vacances
nous avons débloqué 5 millions d'euros
pour ce faire monsieur le député nous
irons plus loin encore et notamment dans
le cadre du plan d'action contre la
radicalisation et le terrorisme présenté
le 9 mai dernier par le premier ministre
manuel valls la prévention spécialisée
fait partie des priorités de ce goût